我觉得这周我们主要说一下联储的政策
因为行业可能我上一次有几次其他的场合里面
讲了不少关于那个行业的东西
我到时候发给你们可以听一下
然后那个比较长
我今天主要讲一下联储的政策
然后我解读一份方答给的关于美国电力的报告
就是这个我觉得可能对后面后续是会有一些影响
本质上我其实觉得现在比方说利率上升
这些东西对AI的影响并没有那么大的
然后因为联储现在在Jackson Hall的时候
我是相当相对来说比较鹰派
所以给市场一个印象就是
深吸的可能会不会导致我们变成2000年
现在我正好现在觉得我身边的那些金多头就感觉现在是2000年
然后空头觉得现在是2000年要炸了
然后多头觉得现在是1998年
我是比较算是多头的
但没有人觉得现在这个AI是一个产业革命
比方说它现在是1950年没有人这样感觉
所以我觉得没有一次
我们历史上的泡沫会在所有人都觉得它是泡沫的时候发生是一个泡沫
00年的时候没有人觉得它是个泡沫都觉得它是一个产业革命界的东西
觉得我们互联网以后老厉害了老牛了现在大家都是在硬设00年
这个状态我觉得你们可以关注一下
然后为什么说我觉得解读一下北联储的这个Jackson Hall的讲话吧
然后他对那个长端的一些影响
然后最后会对市场造成的一些影响
首先
上一次能方配入的数据确实是非常差
然后在这个非常差的能方配入的情况下
就是在数据已经很差的情况下
美联Wash它的态度还是要去控制通胀
这个是Jackson Hall的主线条
然后他说那个数据现在不足以支持等于
不足以支持知道那个通胀一定会加价
他的Focus他的关注点是在通胀上
所以被解读成一个非常Hawkwish
非常硬派的这边一个讲话
看一下就是
我可以看一下Rates
就比较说现在加息的概率相当于啥是非常高的
就是大家基本上觉得60%觉得会加息
这个数据后面那个数就没有更新
我可能更新时候有点问题
但我昨天看的话大概是60%左右会有加息的概率
然后这个东西对在市场上立即的影响
对于长端和短端是不一样
这个图你们可以看
就是对于利率你这个看Normal Interest
对于十年期利率基本没影响
然后对于两年期五年期肯定是有影响的
就是相当于说整个利率曲线变平了
然后觉得长端短端的利率会上升
然后长端我能控制通脏
所以市场上有一种说法
就是Wash出来说比较硬派的话
是为了控制长端利率
然后Balcent是当然是更加在乎长端利率的
就是说白宫的目标其实是希望这个市场
就特朗普和白宫
他们对于市场的反应就是希望市场其实涨
或者是他在执政的时候希望经济变好
经济变好市场涨
然后不太希望失业的情况很严重
又影响他选情
然后所以Balcent确定的是一直是非常关注
这个十年期利率
但十年期利率没动
就说有市场上有种说法说Wash
其实是为了控制十年的利率
然后去做的这个比较硬派的讲话
我觉得这个是肯定是不对的
也就是这个是我跟很多在说宏观的人
看法很大有很大的不同
美联储控制长端利率已经有15年了
所以他如果要去控制长端利率
他有一百种办法去控制长端利率
他可以把美联储回购什么东西
稍微改一改
或者是就是后领
他手上还有的国家的后领
把它放成长端
斩击斩一下
斩成长端
长端就马上就下来
所以长端其实一直在被控制
我们可以看我上周其实讲过这个事情
然后我再recorder一下
再回顾一下
也就是我们曾经
2000年到00年到08年
Financial crisis之前
它是一个周期性的
就有的时候长端高给
说长端低一点
对于Norminal Interest Rate
那个20年这个周期划掉的话
我们现在这个周期是一直在控制长端
就是美联储其实一直在做QE
那我们要把QE的力量拿掉的话
长端利率最终是应该去和Norminal GDP
去契合
那么这个契合的过程
其实意味着你在当下这个利率
就应该到完之六以上
百率连五
然后是不是我因为我控制利率的预期很高
所以我长端能够很好控制
在短期是这样子
也就是Jackson后之后的反应
30年期已经掉来了
对吧
30年期对于那个对于那个
因为长端利率更多的是通胀的预期
增长的预期
然后还有连处
你对于这个控制的影响
这三个事情
所以你把这东西真正去掉的话
那么你短期里面
你认为通胀会下来
但是通胀能不能下倒
或者我们就要Normal growth嘛
就是我们11季的增长
能不能下到现在的利率
比方说4.7
现在4.7吧
10年期
下到4.7以下
我觉得这很难
这个你通胀要下两
通胀和增长两个东西加一起
要下200qb
就下来下百分之二
你就算我们现在通胀的组成部分
比方说石油
比方说我们的核心通胀
然后比方说关税
这些影响你把它全部降下来
那么整个长端利率
你在连处没有监管的情况下
它还是继续往上走
那么美联储现在如果决定
它是要进行加息的周期
像我说的
它要进行加息周期
那么我们在未来一年里面
会面临一个什么样的状况
在未来一年里面
我们会面临长端利率
短端利率往上走
同时的话
长端还是要去找到我的Normal growth
那么Cabinwash这人
我觉得有两种可能
也就是第一种可能
它就是真的
injuristic
就是这个狂热性的
认为我就是要把通脏控制住
不管川普怎么想
不管我当时跟川普讲过什么东西
我就是要把这个通脏控制住
而且通知在20%内
这的Spot of FAT中间有一个
他也认识到的问题
就是AI
AI使得我们现在经济体
在美国吧
你们说我们
这个美国的经济体
目前的状况是K shape
是条K型
这个K shape
现在大家
他也非常清楚
这K shape在两个层次
第一个层次在私营部门和公共部门
第二层次是在AI和非AI
也就是我们私营部门
就美国的私营部门
当利率高的时候
它是受利率影响最多的
我借的房贷
我车贷
我借的买房子
然后我做的商业地产
然后融资
然后这些公司扩张
扩张
我花钱去建一个新的新马克店
这个回馈的周期都是10年以上
所以他对利率敏感度是非常高
国家对利率敏感度是非常低的
所以当利率真正在上升的时候
在拜登期间
也是上升过
未来让经济不崩掉
他要做更多的
Government Spanning
Fitical Spanning
就是你的货币政策
当你被迫变得更紧的时候
你的财政政策
其实是变得更松的
财政政策要花钱
这个 somehow某一种程度上
本身就会抵消掉
财政政策对于通胀的影响
会比货币政策更加直接
更加快
所以它会部分的抵消掉
货币政策
本身对经济的一个影响
也就是你真正要通过降息
然后升息
然后去控制通胀
其实你要财政配合
你是让经济其实实际上
进入一个半水
有点衰退的状态
或经济既然过热
你让它不要过热
但是这是一个可以选择
但是政策制定者在美国是很难完成的
也就是我们在拜登时期已经看到了
就是你在升息的时候
你的货币政策其实使得经济体变成可以选
使得国家支出这个比率变得更高
这个并不是Kavin Wash
或者是共和党们想做的事情
就是Kavin Wash的本质
也是要把这个利率给到市场
所以当市场需要的利率的时候
去市场去调解这东西
然后让国家也不要借那么多钱
然后第二个可以是
是AI和非AI
这我其实上周也说过
我们也讲过这个问题
就是AI它是2.2年回本
就这就是阿利的报告
就是你投一个酸力中心
就两年半回本
两年2.2年回本
那你在两年多一点点回本的东西
它是不是会在意
我现在是6.5厘钱
4.5厘钱
它是不在意的
但是你开一个星巴克店
你是在意
你是5.5厘钱
还是4.5厘钱
所以你这K-shape的状态中间
如果利率变高
其实是相当于不恰当的比率
就是你AI是个iGEM
它吸收了更多的资源
你直接进去搞话聊的话
你是把其他细胞给杀掉
然后让iGEM长得更快
因为你这个东西对iGEM是不用的
就是它的投资收益率实在太高了
所以如果Kavin Wash
我觉得现在有两条路径
就第一条路径
我是真的非常执着于通胀
然后我真的是很想去加息
真的是想加息
然后去控制通胀
它是一定会失败
这个失败在于两个方面
第一个方面
本次通胀根本就不是你加息能解决的
本次通胀是输入性的
我们叫做supply
就是供应端的通胀
供应端通胀
比方说我在电子源旗舰里面
你内存不够
内存不够
数据容量拼命的接见
你加到10%
你能阻止数据中心不去见吗
不可能
数据中心见和不见
我大伙会去讲这个问题
它是电力的问题
是审批的问题
政策问题
这个会演化数据中心
但是你加息加到10
对数据中心影响是0
就是增加的增量的数据中心
会不会去见去做
没有影响
但是我现在供应的短缺
我对芯片供应短缺
我对于内存供应短缺
那我苹果是不是要加加
还是要加加
买苹果会变少
大家没工作
然后买苹果变少
但是数据中心不太会
它是二阶
等于你们这些人全没钱
然后才会变成更多的
才会影响数据中心的
就是token的使用
这都甚至都不会
因为当我真的利率变高了
我经济变差了
我的实体第一件事情
我是把人先砍掉
而不是把token先砍掉
因为token比人便宜
做表的能不用人的
本来我钱多
我能够让人去用AI
然后完成的工作
我就让人用AI完成了
当我经济利率变高了
我生存环境变差了
我先把人给砍了
所以你面临的问题
如果你植作一同仗
在k-shape的经济体里面
你造成对于k-shape的往下的实体
造成的影响会大得多的多
所以我们现在的经济在拋除
我给你看一下能光配合
在拋除AI的情况下
已经在
包括AI情况下
你现在就业都是负的
就上一次来就能放配合就业都是负的
你不要说你还囊获了AI的情况
你还不说你跑掉AI的情况
你如果把它跑掉
那个经济体是非常非常负面
在负面的情况下
你准备怎么去加息
你加息影响是谁
影响是开打茶店的
然后开饭店的那些
那些影响会更加严重
影响严重的多
因为本身是大家平均受伤害
在你一个没有产业革命的时候
是平均受伤害
你有的时候
你是虚别性受伤害
政府不受伤害
不要算一样会借钱
不会因为5%
那个长端变了5%
然后你告诉我美国这个不负债
然后负债债务爆掉
这是不可能的
美国债务本质
美元是美元
美元本质就是因为它欠债钱的
你可以看看历史
英国为什么时候打赢拿破轮战争
因为人家一直在欠债
人家把国债市场做起来
这个我就不展开说
但这个我长期的一个观点
就是你不要觉得什么美国欠债
有美国债务问题没有的
但是你们这个实力应急
受到双倍的打击
政府借钱比你不在乎
然后AI借钱不在乎
所以如果你执着于
我觉得它有两种可能
如果你是执着于通胀影响的话
那么会进入个政策错误
政策错误在短期里面
对长端市有压制作用
看上去是没有问题
但是最终大家会
realize会意识到这个问题
你当你长端没有人管的时候
没有人管那个中间是差200个倍
是180个点
就是这个时候差180个点
你中间必须是差180到190
是个基点1.8到1.9
你不可能1.8到1.9
全部通过这个通胀预期来影响
supply side就是供应端的那个通胀
包括油价也是你打了个账
你成油价弄成这个样子
然后你加息油价能下来吗
不能下来
你能够控制多少油的需求呢
油的需求挤压权是中国人在挤压
因为中国严重的通缩
所以中国经济体本身就在挤压
而且战略上也在做挤压
所以为什么能够维持住
现在油价这个水平
因为中国在帮你做空前
这不是你自己跟你加息
没有一毛钱的关系
就你加息是不能够影响
我觉得这个是我对
开问我是这个政策的一个影响
那它是不是这样做
我觉得不一定是
第二种可能就是A选择谁
我觉得三个选择
我们说第二个选择
就是它真的原来说是加息
而原来它说是降息
然后它是其实是想放松的
那我觉得现在它在杰克森后讲完这话
这个降息基本上就不太好看
然后那就滑掉
那就第二种可能
真正第二种可能的话
是它其实看到能方倍率很差
它知道进去数据会变很差
所以给它有底气去讲非常鹰派的话
然后在直接做的时候
美联储从来没有
就近代以来
近代我们就80年以后
其实50年以后
我觉得美联储
就我知道的美联储数据以来
这个因为统计82年以后
80年以后
没有一次在能方倍率
就两个负的能方倍率的情况下
去做过任何一次加息
近代没有发生过这个事情
已经40年了
没有发生过事情
然后我觉得很有可能
下一次能方倍率还是负的
为什么呢
就是你看很多前瞻性的这个指标
比方说job opening是个前瞻性的指标
也就是你现在看到比方说
你说经济过热
或者是有通胀吧
这不是智障和智障是你的
生产效率没有办法提高
然后在70年的时候
你石油价钱涨上去
然后你本身生息
对那个注入清涨也没有什么影响
然后你说你产生了智障
但是美国现在不是智障
它现在是K shape
K shape意味着
就是说其实在某一部分的经济
它是蓬勃发展的
发展非常非常快
这个矮正总游细胞涨很快
AI涨很快
然后在另外一部分
它就发展很慢
然后你看到综合数据
你感觉是智障
其实并不是
它是一个K shape
那么K shape那个涨的那一块
其实没有很多的就业的
那为什么
我当话也会说到这个问题
为什么美国有这么多的老百姓
比方说学民
现在口碑是非常反酸力中心的
除了中国在抖音
这个小红是吧
在在美国
包括X平台
大量制造各种各样账号
鼓动美国人去反对酸力中心
以外
这个中国也在做
那个因为你要战略之后人家
所以中国人在做利息的事情
说这个是这些原因以外
其实
酸力中心给美国老百姓
没有带来太大的好处
除了取代他们的工作
你在花钱建一个酸力中心
在这个地区
然后总的让酸力变多
让我板领的工作没有
然后那里弄了很吵
让我垫架上去
对我有什么好处
就是我上次说过不恰当的比喻
就是世界会变成0.1%的神族的人
然后99.9的从主的人
就是你是被养的那个猪
还是你要获得更用更多的酸力
做更聪明的事情
然后把原来觉得不可能事情全部去做一遍
对于前者的1%的人
当然我要拼命建酸力中心了
那个黄仁勋天天想去干这个事情
但是对于大部分的美国
做自担死的白领
你每天就手上拿一个工章
然后做表格的人
对你没有好处的
所以在政策上是会有影响
但是确实
酸力中心也不制造
酸力中心AI本身
也不制造大家的工作点
然后你看
job opening和工资的数据
工资上涨数据
这些前瞻性的东西
就注定的经济体不会好
经济体实际不会好
包括你会看到消费的数据
其实都不好
retail sales上市也不好
这已经retail sales就已经不是前瞻性数据了
已经是现行的这些数据了
所以从这些数据综合来看
我是觉得
这个往下调的券的是一个持续性
那为什么前一段时间能够
经济数据你看那个能方
可能稍微好一点
有点退税
退税本身是对经济是有帮助的
但是现在你再走到年底
马上40万亿
41万亿40万亿的税务上限要到
税务上限要到了以后
你连财政的那些口子政策的钱都出本案
也就是你实体
现在你会看到包括美国的估值里面
你实体的那些公司
星巴克是在36倍批付我的
今年36倍
付我的忘了多少
你36倍
英伟达在12倍批
所以这是个泡沫吗
这是一个什么样的泡沫
一个增长百分之一个毛利率
70% 74%的公司
增长75%
它在12倍批
然后你认为这个是周期
然后另外一边经济体在变差
消费也在变差
然后你给了一个15%毛利的公司
增长15%的公司
3日倍批
所以我觉得
经资本行业资本市场里面
也在做K系统的风化
也就是风化到
当我们看到半导体和那些
大家都在说泡沫
大家都在说2000年
都在以恐惧的心态看着
不管他取代你的工作
还是觉得他固执过高
但是事实上这些公司
如果你看到他follower
locking屁
远期的屁
和业绩的增长
就是他们是往下的
新兴生产力
现在在估值上是往下的那个来
旧生产力可可可乐
沃尔玛
然后新法可
是往上的那个来
就是现代市场非常魔幻
风化
那么
所以我觉得是这样一个状况
那么说回Kevin Walsh
Kevin Walsh
我觉得第二种可能
就是他认为这个经济
经济数据是为了很差的
所以他能够去讲一些更硬的话
在9月份时候
不会加息
那我觉得这种可能比较大
我个人感觉这种可能会比较大
那么如果他采取第一种
就是加息这个政策
十年期会在短期里面
一两个月里面
会被稳定住
觉得真的能够控制动涨
但是市场还会realize do not verify
不要跟那个美联储对得干
然后美联储既然已经加息
他更加不会去管长期了
那么在明年或者在今年下半年
最后的那个score 4
然后到明年
十年期的利率还是会控制不住
他还是会往上跑的
所以你会面临一个什么样的情况
加息不能加很多次
你会面临一个BS deepening
就是这个不是马上
但是我觉得年底
如果你真的加息
会面临BS deepening
那么对实体的伤害
是非常非常严重
美国在加息的过程中间
不管你加息还是不加息
还有一种决定不加息
不加息你长端还是会往上走
长端往上走
其实是只要连处
你不控制
你这长端都要往上走
那么长端往上走的结果
我上周其实已经说过了
结果就是调整估值
调整估值
我有没有估值
有调整估值
其实那个二六年已经调整估值
二六年的负货批
一直在掉到二十以下
以前是二三倍二四倍
二三倍二四倍
从今年高的时候
现在被调整到了
比方说二十倍
可以继续调整
可以调整回
比方说一八年的水平
这是负货批
所以你说S&P在涨
S&P很贵吗
没有很贵
当然了
你如果货币政策实在太紧
他也可以调回到
比方说你真正印钱钱的水平
但是为什么每股估值
在变便宜
因为那些公司的业绩在涨
谁的业绩在涨
KCPE网上的那些
KCPE网下的那些是不涨
所以远离
远离增长慢的公司
远离那些真正估值高
就增长慢才是估值高
最大的估值贵就是增长慢
这个是我看法
然后说一下市场的不得选
市场不得选两块
那个简单来讲
Hatch Farm Position
我们之前一直讲到的那个
叫什么动能
其实Hatch Farm Position
现在来说已经改善很多了
我们上周好像已经说过了
就是有很多动能票比方说
半导体啊
这些动能已经变成短期
做空的那个来的
也就是原来我都
我都是综合在一起
然后我短期和长期
做多那个那个
全是半导体
然后做空各种各样的东西
所以当你一旦那个动能
要去平仓的时候
波动大的时候
那你的半导体被杀了很多
就AI不是半导体
整个AI被杀了很多
因为你仓位很集中
但现在不是
长期的还是在做多AI
但是在短期的已经变成做空了
所以你即使发生平仓
或者市场波动
它的影响不可能
像7月份6月份这么严重
而且整个系统性的杠杆
现在不搞
就没有像7月份的时候那么高
你要放在几年的周期来看
它确实可能是挺高
但是你要放在一两个月的周期的话
其实并没有很高
两个说你一两个月周期
你说就是流动性
我看一下那个
prime book
两个说你放在六个月的周期
它其实是个D位
对吧
这个上去
但是最近稍微
levels上去一些
就gross levels
总的levels上去一些
但是比高的时候
还是相当于去年
代表说12月份的水平
第二
我们在prime book
这是对冲基金的仓位
然后
然后那个
这个是fundamental book
也就是我们两说
mutual fund
那些longshore fund
就长期持有的资金
它的仓位已经降低到了
liberation day
就是美国
川普不是刚上来搞了一个liberation
那么解放日嘛
已经到了解放日的水平
也就是我们现在市场仓位
从基金角度来说
现在很轻
我不知道BOA的那个报告说
我们现在那个指数
那个非业指数
就是那个
我们现在看多牛市指数很高
然后现在仓位很接近
我不知道它这个数据哪里来的
这个是高盛的
至少从这个角度来讲
现在的仓位完全不高
这是一个
第二个
从快列market上
那个信贷市场上来看
信贷市场上
我们经历了很多次巨大的融资
博康说要融60个别列
600亿
那它就要建设算计中心
还没有
但是methos auto
在年初融了20个别列
然后那个谷狗融了
在澳大利亚这还发了5.5个别列
这个都在ig上
就在investment grade上面发的
然后这个investment grade上面发的
大概这个是8月初吧
这个是8月初
这个可能是8月中
对于investment grade的市场来说
就是我们叫ig的那个快列
没有特别大的影响
我们基本上对于这个信贷市场的
吸收程度还是很好
然后还有的
还有在一个地位
也就是我之前也讲过
就是真正缺钱
我们说缺钱这个事情
我一直说缺钱是三月中心里
有很大的问题
缺钱这个事情
是会让他们因为需求增加
就会让他们的快列 spread往上跑
你可以看到那个
这个是相当于investment grade
就是那个借款成本
一直在往上跑
然后还有的现在
现在这段时间flat
那么他这个借款多了
他一定是往往上跑
但是中间要注意两个事情
就第一个就是
我们在评判四个云场的快列 spread
会不管上跑的时候
对市场有多大影响的时候
就是你要看总量
这个总量最终会让市场可能会害怕的时候
可能会害怕是要到明年
现在是在信贷市场上炒预期
炒预期的时候可以去布局
可以去买cds
这文免我也干了这个事情
你买了cds
然后cds要赚钱
但是要清楚真正出问题并不是今天
出问题可能是明年
所以现在在这几个星期至少来看
所有量化的指标并没有发生联动
你会不会发生暴仓
没有还有个vote
还有那个还有vote
比方说AI denominated
就是AI的这个AI的那个波动率
波动率没有下来
没有上去
这种不算上去
你之前120了
你现在现在可能只有多少
现在只有66
所以你vote基本下降了一半
就这个是我们的AI basket的那个vote
那么你AI的vote
你就是加总在一起的vote
没有双框关联度
然后这个vote
它平均的数字下降了
将近一半
那么这个东西的结果就是
有很多策略会发生去加仓的
因为momentum策略本身
它调整vote control
就是根据vote来调整的
那么这个是其实也表明了一个问题
它就没有保藏
你不管就前段时间
比方说也早被吵这个新闻
吵完以后怎么样
它没有保藏
没有deliverage
然后在快列market
对快列市场没有影响
至少你看ig吧
还有吧
还有是没有影响
所以这一些东西是就表明了
就说现在市场的仓位并没有那么不好
那总结一下
我就觉得Kavin Wash的态度
我觉得两条路
就是这个两条路里面的一条石油
可能是
我觉得更有可能的
它感觉数据更差
然后k-shape的经济下面
它如果真的升息的话
会对市场造成很负面意义
对ai反而不会造成很大影响
然后整体市场的比较凶
我觉得现在
现在来说相对的说比较健康
你不能跟三年前两年前比
但是在短期里面相对来说是比较健康
然后我想最后再花五分钟
然后我简单说一下
因为今天不多ql
我简单说一下
那个防打一篇报告
然后关于美国真正有可能影响
美国算理容性和AI建设的一个内容
那你可以看
就是它有多少算力
真正按照covS算出来的
这里按照covS算出来的
算力的提供大概是50GW
然后这个50GW在美国建设35GW
预期35GW
但是能够预期能够建出来多少
这个gap是非常非常大
也就是它能够
比方说过去每一年
过去年每年大概是过去一年
过去12个月
一共点了11.4GW
这个和你明年预期35
预期差很大
而且明年35GW的预期里面
你比方说真正通电的
现在路条能够通电的就11到14GW
11到14GW
就这个数字
很蓝色
11到14GW
那么这个数字是不可能提高的
就你花多少钱都没有用
现在在美国算力中心
被Q的Ratio
就是你比方说你放弃了
你这个是Announce
我说要建380GW
但是其实我比方说
我真正放弃了
我中间有放弃的是43GW
这个放弃43GW中间78%
78%是被政策性Q掉的
就是被政策性倒带
只有1%是项目方自己说不见
几乎没有
因为很赚钱
那么美国政策去批准算力中心建设
这个事情才是一个
我觉得后面比较大的一个合作
就是实时老百姓中间没有获利
然后你们要建这么多东西
你要搞A跟我有什么关系
所以民意上
特别在中期选举前
在民意上
在州政府层面
他们对这东西的压力越来越大
那么这个黄色的是什么
是自建电网
自建电网比方说
他把一个涡轮发电机
从那个飞机上给拆下来
有不同路径
比方说涡轮发电机
从飞机上给拆下来
这个tablet
然后拆下来
然后把它装上去
比方说用比翼的方案
比翼方案上去是不需要批准
然后boom energy
所以你还是要很佩服南西普罗前
他对政治上的敏感度
他很知道这个行业的政治上的压力
在哪里
然后他是不需要批准的
对吧
但是如果你用G1V的那种大的发电机
你可能要等四年五年
现在的所有的这个发电机
就G1V他们已经发电机到了2031年
这就是为什么
黄仁勋一直在讲
他说中国和美国的这个AI竞赛
中国China wins 中国肯定赢
因为中国去部署这个电力
一年就搞定了
中国没有什么路条
没有旁边社区反对
然后那个很多东西都没有
很多整批过程都没有
人家一年就可以部署
你这玩意
你真正部署大的
你要四年到五年
病网要到三一年以后了
你现在现在的所有的算力
在明年可能会出来的
我们说在这中间可能会出来
十一到十字几瓦的这个算力
这个电是二五年以二五年的时候
申请你现在申请到三一年以后
所以电力的供应在哪里
这个可能会是一个问题
也就是我们会从芯片的
你要看算力中心部署里面
因为原来有很多建完的算力中心
相当于它有瓶子
里面还没有把酒给装进去
卡没有买进去
所以现在卡买进去的时候
卡缺在哪里
比方说缺它存储
缺在哪里
那么这些东西是对它更加敏感
那么在未来一段时间
就是27年比方说28年
部署电力的缺口会越来越大
因为你原来是多给了电力
那时候容易
现在审批变难了
所以你后来越来越多
那瓶子也会不够用
瓶子不够用
你用Otternative
现在二手飞机都卖掉了
二手飞机都去发电去了
对吧
那就给给他们做那个发电
然后说你部署Otternative电力的需求
就会慢慢变成更大的瓶子
所以这个关注这个趋势
然后你中间Deliver 50GW的卡
那50GW卡你慢慢部署到境外去
所以原来是美国也不缺电
中国也不缺电
然后美国缺卡
中国缺卡
中国抢不过美国的卡
那么如果说中国不缺电
美国开始缺电
那卡的流向就是哪里有电
我就是哪里有电
然后我做了那个token就是赚钱
所以这个是有可能会让很多竞争格局
有一些改变的状态
所以所以这个是我们可以关注的
就是我觉得AI从经济账上过来
它是毫无疑问
就是你动摇不了它
它是一个A
它是一个I正
但是政策层面
会不会就搞刺化疗呢
或者是搞切割这些
限制你限制你发展
那个这个这个要看
也就是还有个就数字
60%-70%的现在有很多点类
每次专利中心出来都点类
都延期
60%-70%延期
现在都是因为电力的延期
所以这个可能在电力上
我觉得我就amphys再说一下这个事情
好吧
那个看看你们有什么问题吗